in the aftermath of today's sad news on
the loss of steve jobs customers and
analysts investors and of course
employees and naturally tragically his
family members are all wondering now
what they're sayin emptiness and avoid
when something like this happens he's
certainly was a legend and an icon in so
many ways and in in some ways his
departure style we'd consider almost
like that of a monarch he when a monarch
dies as a matter of fact the the palace
crier will say announce the first long
live the king as we have a king to
celebrate and then they announce the
king is dead and then they respond with
long live the king because the new ones
been identified but in this case people
are wondering have we identified the new
one as key constituents are rallying
around the Apple surviving management
team with a superstar group there Tim
Cook of course a no nonsense but
congenial thoughtful operations chief
was now the CEO the great software
computer scientist Scott for Bush Phil
Schiller global sales expert and the
developer of the iPad a great device guy
Jonathan Ives with these sorts of people
around there's a great continuity of
knowledge and expertise and they
probably in fact even have the the the
i5 iphone 5 and iphone 6 stored away
ready for some later stage development
but i'm sure there's some backlog to
carry the company for a while but still
are any of these people the king these
people the new steve jobs and no they
won't be you don't just fabricate a
steve jobs through the going to the
blister pack at a cash register or
trying to get a steve jobs through
college campus or trying to get a Steve
Jobs stuff by just identifying someone
in your management development program
and your succession charts or in the
Messianic search of an exec you
of recruiting firm they're very hard to
identify because this is not just
getting another talented business leader
which is sometimes hard enough to do on
its own this is to go out and find a
folk hero and business leaders every now
and then become folk hero sometimes its
warriors sometimes it's politicians
wherever society's greatest uncertainty
is we look for a hero to give us a code
of conduct and that's what Steve Jobs
would do give us a path a way of
understanding how to make sense of the
technological revolutions around us and
make it part of our life he made it less
threatening he understood the consumer I
actually met steve jobs in the early 80s
when I was having a lunch with Ed lad
the founder of Polaroid as jobs who'd
already been pushed out of Apple came
running over to our table not see me but
to see Ed land the Polaroid he said Oh
dr. land dr. land it's so great to see
you you're such a legend to me in the
creation of my last company I modeled it
on this great noble experiment of
progressive management practices and
being on the edge of science and
technology and society and doing it my
new company and Ed land said roll this
is dr. sonnenfeld and I'm sorry I don't
know who you are I've he would have
recognized in two football fields away
but job said oh I'm Steve Jobs I created
apple computer I'm now creating next and
I'm looking for space and Ed lands who
actually owned the building most of
other than the restaurant was a garage
land said well how about this building
he said all that'd be great i could
expand in here and jobs just walked lad
walked out shaking his head saying Steve
Jobs I don't know it kids not going to
make it he just never understood his
technology sadly II DeLand created two
Polaroid as a great company that was
stuck in its technology it didn't move
ahead whereas jobs not only understood
technology but he understood the users
of technology that what many engineers
would diminish as inconsequential which
was how the products used how it's
marketed how it affects our lives that's
what Steve Jobs understood his
technological visions forever have
transformed so many parts of
communications in
tainment and and fundamental industries
but that sweeping technological impact
is one great quality of a folk hero
another one is the is the common touch
the common origins here this child
abandoned at Birth as I put up for
adoption and dropout from from Reed
College and there's a common touch about
him his kids went to public school so
folks can identify with him a third
quality of a folk hero it's not just the
common touch and the transforming
technologies because this is also what
what Thomas Edison and Alexander Graham
Bell and Andrew Carnegie and others have
done is he had setbacks even Thomas
Edison who one of his early inventions
was the two-way flow of communications
on a telegraph wire Jay Gould the robber
baron had manipulated things to take
control of that invention some other
inventions of Edison said Walt Disney
failed two times before launching the
Walt Disney Company Henry Ford failed
twice before getting the ford motor
company off the ground these were
scarring incidences but had helped them
transform who they were they their
character was tempered and tested by the
adversity and they were different
leaders when they came back again Steve
Jobs was different when he came back to
Apple he is quite divisive early on an
apple much more inspiring as he returned
to Apple another quality that they have
is they also have large sweeping visions
for all of society they aren't content
to just deal with the brick and mortar
of their own business but what this
business can mean for others around them
these are ways where Steve Jobs is again
more than a business leader but an
authentic folk hero and what we need to
do is to try to learn how do we deal
with people that are sometimes a little
volatile explosive and creative Steve
Jobs was a difficult person at times
some might say Jeff Bezos has the
challenging moments of the founder and
CEO of amazon or sergey brin and larry
page of google or Mark Zuckerberg today
of a Facebook is they often tend to be
entrepreneurs because our large
companies tend to crush that kind of
challenging spirit Sigmund Freud reminds
us that it's these people that he called
society's discontents who forever
changed the world in fact they often
think in in terms of a mortal quest
through their work we need to learn how
to operationalize that and embrace that
in ways that doesn't hurt other people
by their sometimes toxic personalities
but they're never done they're never
come Robert Motherwell the great painter
once said that the wonderful thing about
the creative process is that it's never
done the the anguish of the uncompleted
work and the pleasurable challenge is
always still there and he refers to
artists will sneak into galleries at
night to touch things up that's the kind
of person that Steve Jobs is that's what
the kind of person that we need to
create and last week I was in Singapore
onstage with the head of China's
state-owned enterprises and he was to 75
percent of China's economy he is talking
about why they're going to keep the
state-owned enterprises because they
have more patient capital than a lot of
Western free enterprise that's become so
short-term oriented they thought that's
a competitive strength and it has some
advantages we have to admit but what it
doesn't have is the ability to capture
these entrepreneurs these rest of souls
these people that want to push the edge
take risks and that's what we need to
figure out how we continue to cultivate
and identify people who have had
setbacks and see that those people in
fact as they conquer adversity are truly
heroic figures and need to be celebrated
thank you very much